the world is strange the whole universe
is very strange but when you look at the
details the rules of the game are very
simple one of physics greatest Minds
Richard Fineman once compared
deciphering the laws of reality to
watching the gods play chess except in
this case you're only allowed to watch
Snippets of the match and can often only
view a tiny corner of the board from
these scant Clues and snatched glimpses
you have to work out the rules behind
the movements of the pieces and instead
of rugs Knights and porns you must
attempt to decipher the laws governing
fundamental particles such as electrons
photons and
quarks sometimes these investigations
bring forth great Revelations at first
you may notice that a bishop always
stays on the same colored squares watch
for long enough though and you'll
discover that while true there is an
even more fundamental rule at play
Bishops can only move diagonally which
in turn explains why they always stay on
the same colored squares the history of
understanding our world is littered with
similar Revelations often two sets of
rules are suddenly married together into
one what looked complex instantly gets
simpler two apparently separate forces
revealed to be actually two sides of the
same coin two particles just equal and
opposite vibrations the Ying to each
other's yang
but the path to this point has been an
arduous one every time physicists have
thought they were getting close to
understanding all the rules they have
spotted some tiny hole in their theory
that they can't explain it's the
equivalent of one of the special moves
in chess
castling this is when the king moves
more than one space and swaps order with
the Rook castling simultaneously breaks
three of the normal rules of Chess and
yet can be a very powerful move a
decisive move in any match as Fineman
said it's the thing that doesn't fit
that's most
interesting it has to do with curiosity
it has to do with people wondering what
makes something do something what we are
looking for is how everything works what
makes everything
work this long and winding road has
delivered modern physicists to the
precipice of a remarkable breakthrough
when might not need an endless list of
ever more complicated rules instead it
is possible that all phenomena in the
known universe from the tiniest
subatomic particles to all the
fundamental forces and so by extension
even ourselves can be explained using
just one
rule that almost everything is simply
vibrations in a vast web of quantum
Fields but is this really the end of the
game or are there still quirks in the
rule book lurking just Out Of
[Music]
Reach thank you to better help for
sponsoring this video everything we call
real is made of things that cannot be
regarded as real the world of
theoretical physics is full of moments
that pull the rug from under you and so
is day-to-day life sometimes you just
need someone to help you organize your
thoughts betterhelp is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100%
online with betterhelp you can tap into
a network of over 30,000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues whether
existential questions like what is
everything made of to more downto Earth
problems to get started you just answer
a few questions about your need needs
and preferences that way better help can
match you with the right therapist from
their network with better help you get
the same professionalism and quality you
expect from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
with more scheduling flexibility and at
a more affordable price so get 10% off
your first month at betterhelp.com
hot and I've also linked them Below in
the description thanks to better help
for supporting educational content on
YouTube
and then to discover if you try to get
answers that they are related to each
other that things that make the wind
make the waves that the motion of water
is like the motion of air is like the
motion of sand the fact that things have
common features it turns out to be more
and more Universal what we are looking
for is how everything works what makes
everything work
cities and continents whiz by as the
Japanese Hitomi satellite hurtles around
the earth at almost 30,000 kilm per hour
it is racing so fast it sees 15 sunrises
and sunsets each and every day with a
total spend of 300 million 30 years to
build it was conceived to look at some
of the most violent events in the known
universe yet within weeks of launch it
would meet a violent end of its
[Music]
own a catastrophic system failure sends
its spinning out of control the team
behind the mission triy firing on board
thrusters to slow it down but that only
makes Hitomi spin faster it is now
rotating so quickly that its solar
panels Shear off and the satellite
breaks apart into pieces the mission
over before it is barely
begun but why what brought down
htoi the ensuing investigation
discovered that the initial failure
occurred isomi passed over the South
Atlantic anomaly a dent in the Earth's
magnetic field this exposed it to higher
levels of radiation from space frying
its delicate circuitry the Earth's
magnetism usually acts like a giant
bubble protecting us from the ravages of
such radiation it begins deep in the
bowels of the planet as the Earth's
molon outer core spins surging through
the crust and out into space it spreads
its magnetic tendrils out to around 6
million kilm the South Atlantic anomaly
is caused by a magnetic reversal in a
small part of the outer core and
satellites passing through the region
are left
vulnerable and so though it may pass by
unseen in our daily lives the magnetism
all around us is extremely
[Music]
powerful humans have been fascinated
with the Earth's magnetic M for
Millennia the first compasses were made
2,000 years ago during the Han Dynasty
in China when naturally magnetized
pieces of iron called load Stones were
used for Land Navigation centuries
earlier the ancient Greek philosopher
thales of meitus thought load Stones had
Souls because they attracted iron to
them but it took far longer for
scientists to explain magnetism and in
doing so a fascinating New Concept
crystallized the field
in physics a field is a region in which
each point has a physical quantity
associated with it television weather
forecasts are a good example because
they show how the temperature varies
across a given region of the Earth's
surface those maps are temperature
Fields they tell you the temperature
you'd experience if you were placed in a
particular part of the map similarly the
Earth's magnetic field is a map
illustrating the strength and direction
of the magnetic force a particle would
feel at various points around the planet
the South Atlantic anomaly is a part of
the map where the Earth's magnetic field
is particularly weak the International
Space Station has extra shielding to
deal with the increased radiation that
lets in and astronauts aren't allowed to
Space Walk while passing through this
region first used by English scientist
Michael Faraday in 1846 he saw Fields as
more than mere mathematical Maps he
considered them physical objects that
fill otherwise empty space
and to illustrate this Faraday used this
idea to help explain the perplexing
behavior of ordinary bar
magnets at some point every child
becomes fascinated with the magic of
magnets try and push two North Poles
together and they resist you can feel
them pushing apart from one another how
can they do that without even touching
what's going on in the space between
them them farad's answer was that the
magnets may not be touching but their
magnetic fields are his explanation
introduced the concept of field lines
you may remember the classic School
experiment of sprinkling iron filings
around a bar magnet which Trace out the
magnet's field lines looping out of the
North Pole and back into the South Pole
the magnetic field is strongest at these
poles and so the field lines are packed
more tightly together at least that's
the 19th century when of thinking about
it as we will see the truth is much
stranger yet that was not the end of
Faraday's genius his most famous
discovery came when he found that
changing a magnetic field can induce an
electric current in a nearby circuit a
decade earlier the Danish physicist Hans
Christian stad had spotted the reverse
that an electric current passing through
a wire deflected a nearby compass needle
away from magnetic north clearly a
changing magnetic field could influence
an electric field and vice versa why
were the two Fields so
connected the answer would come from
Scottish physicist James Clark
Maxwell in 1865 Maxwell describes
Faraday and Ed's discoveries
mathematically this work is so important
that in 1999 leading physicists voted
Maxwell the third greatest physicist of
all time behind only Einstein and
Newton Maxwell's equations should show
that rather than being two separate
Fields electric fields and magnetic
fields are both components of a single
electromagnetic field that's why
changing one changes the other you're
altering parts of the same thing Maxwell
had combined two seemingly separate
phenomena into one in the chess game of
the Gods spotting that changing magnetic
fields and electric Fields influence
each other is the equivalent of
realizing that the the Knight always
alternates between white and black
squares uniting them into the
electromagnetic field is akin to
discovering that's because the Knight
always moves in an L shape you reached a
deeper more comprehensive understanding
of the
rules and the Quest for similar
unifications has kept physicists busy
ever since this was just the tip of a
very large scientific Iceberg for
Maxwell had another trick up his
[Music]
sleeve imagine an electrically charged
particle it generates an electric field
around it just like a magnet creates a
magnetic field the particle then starts
moving up and down this changes its
electric field which also then generates
a changing magnetic field according to
Maxwell's equations the constantly
changing Fields produce ripples that
move outwards through the
electromagnetic field
electromagnetic
waves how frequently the particles move
up and down dictates how long it takes
for the Peaks and troughs in the
electromagnetic waves to repeat from his
equations Maxwell calculated the speed
of these electromagnetic waves and the
answer he found was
remarkable they move at the speed of
light surely not a coincidence Maxwell
became convinced that light is itself is
an electromagnetic wave indeed if true
it would explain how sunlight reaches us
despite the sun being 150 million
kilometers away the electromagnetic
field would fill the empty space between
us and light could Rumble through it
like an ocean wave but how could this be
proved
definitively the man with the answer was
Heinrich Herz now so synonimous with
electromagnetic waves that the unit for
measuring how many times they repeat in
a second is named after after
[Music]
him Herz first sets up a device capable
of producing an electric spark then he
readies a receiver 15 M away when the
generator Sparks another spark soon
follows in the receiver to prove that
this is caused by an invisible wave
traveling between the two devices herds
puts a mirror between them he has to
move the receiver in order to get it to
spark again because the mirror reflects
the wave onto A New Path
he's even able to measure the speed of
the wave which turns out to be the speed
of light Herz has discovered radio waves
Maxwell is Vindicated the rules of the
game updated
definitively light was an
electromagnetic
wave and yet something didn't quite fit
light was only an electromagnetic
wave
sometimes remarkably the very same
experiment that provided evidence for
light as an electromagnetic wave would
ultimately show it to be something else
entirely a
particle Herz noticed that the spark at
the receiver was brighter when exposed
to ultraviolet light later experiments
by other scientists including Philip Von
Leonard showed that electrons are
expelled as a metal absorbs light which
is what brightened Herz his spark
brighter light has higher waves so they
should have dislodged more electrons as
they crash into the metal yet Von
Leonard found that it was light waves
that repeat more often those with a
higher frequency and not intensity that
liberated more electrons this became
known as the photoelectric effect and
would Herald perhaps the biggest
revolution in the history of
science an explanation would soon follow
from none other than Albert
Einstein despite being famous for his
theories of Relativity it was this work
on the photoelectric effect that would
land him the Nobel Prize for Einstein
argued that light isn't a continuous
wave at all but a series of particles
fired out like bullets particles that
today we call photons how much energy
each Photon has depends on the light's
frequency and only photons with high
frequencies have enough energy to
dislodge an electron it's similar to a
boxing match lots of continuous low
energy punches do little one sizable
knockout blow is all it
takes this was a truly bizarre Discovery
and one that would force physicists to
concede that their entire chess game was
hideously outdated almost without
exception every rule would need to be
Rewritten complete with startling
Revelations about the true nature of our
reality and even
ourselves by the end of the thread that
Faraday started pulling in
1846 we would find ourselves living in a
totally different
universe but to start with to begin
unfolding the rules of this new game
physicists would have to figure out this
simple mystery why does light come in
packets with set
[Music]
sizes
we are trying to prove ourselves wrong
as quickly as possible because only in
that way can we find
progress as night falls dobri ignites
into a riot for the senses the smell of
Japanese street food wafts through the
air as throngs of people bustle noisily
between the crowded or sakan Alleyways
but it is the Kaleidoscope of color that
hits you most everywhere you look near
neon signs flood the streets with light
advertising king crab octopus balls and
revolving sushi restaurants and deep
within these famous neon signs there's
an equally frantic Hive of activity
unfolding instead of people scurrying
about tiny subatomic particles called
electrons Dart this way and that without
them the streets of doton Bor would be
dark they are also the key to
understanding photons
let's Journey inside one of doton B's
red neon signs which are filled with
hydrogen gas to reach the individual
atoms of hydrogen we have to zoom in an
incredibly long way a hydrogen atom is
almost unfathomably small around 83
million times narrower than one of your
fingernails if you were to shrink the
Earth by the same amount you could hold
the planet in the palm of your
hand hydrogen is the simplest atom in
the universe made of just two particles
a positively charged proton in the
center with a negatively charged
electron whizzing around it although far
from A Perfect Analogy it's similar to
the Hitomi satellite orbiting the Earth
indeed this is how Danish physicist
Neil's bore pictured the hydrogen atom
in 1913 in what has become known as the
bore model however B argued that the
electron cannot inhabit just any orbit
around the proton instead electron
orbits are like the food served in the
doore streets you can't buy a portion in
any size you like you have to choose
between set predetermined quantities
such as small medium or large anything
in between simply doesn't
exist in the bore model electron orbits
are similarly quantized meaning only
certain restricted quantities or sizes
are allowed these permitted orbits are
called energy levels and they are the
secret behind Doon B's cacophony of
color if you pass an electric current
through a gas then you give its
electrons an energy boost which they use
to jump up to a higher energy level when
they fall back down again the energy
they lose is spat out in the form of a
photon the energy of the photon is equal
to the size of the gap between the
energy levels in turn this governs the
color of the light we see red light has
the least energy violet light the
most if all orbits were possible then
we'd only see white light as all the
different colors from the Myriad
transitions Blended together here that
is not what we see if you take the light
from glowing hydrogen gas and pass it
through a device similar to a prism then
you reveal hydrogen's Spectrum the
visible part of this spectrum consists
of just four colored lines painted on a
sea of black these lines come from
photons emitted when electrons drop down
to the second energy level from the
sixth fifth four fourth and third energy
levels
respectively the Blackness between the
lines is a Barren
Wasteland it's devoid of light because
the electron transitions needed to
illuminate it simply don't
exist this pattern is the coing card of
the quantum
atom but of the four lines the red one
on the far right known as H Alpha is
significantly brighter than its
neighbors it is drowns out the other
three and so the streets of Doon borri
are drenched in
Red so far so good not simple but at
least
rational by the 1920s many of History's
Greatest physicists from Max plank to
Einstein to bore had worked on this
model of the atom the result of
following the implications of Einstein's
photoelectric effect to their logical
end but of course in fineman's Cosmic
chess match there was always some tiny
obscure move that blows a gaping hole in
your theory one innocuous observation
that makes you realize everything isn't
quite as it seems and this particular
crack was especially
minuscule if you look carefully at the H
Alpha line You'll see that it isn't one
line at all but two a dublet these lines
almost imperceptibly close together
separated by distance 250,000 times
finer than a strand of spider silk
physicists call this fine structure and
the bore model cannot explain it fine
structure is itself the equivalent of a
big neon sign flashing with a warning
Theory
incomplete once again physicists were
forced to return to the drawing
board and today the solution to the Fine
structure riddle lies on the other side
of the world in a place as popular with
tourists as the street food stalls of
Doon
Buri Westminster
Abbey with its imposing Towers
Westminster Abbey is one of the jewels
in London's Crown kings and queens have
been coronated within its walls for
almost a thousand years it's also the
burial place of many a British icon from
Dickens and Darwin to Kipling and Newton
and on the floor of the Abbey close to
the monument to Newton a plaque
commemorates the life of arguably the
greatest English physicist since Newton
himself Paul Adrien Maurice
durak engraved on the plaque is the
equation that not only represents the
crescendo of D's genius but one that
also resolves the fine structure problem
and explains why the H Alpha line is a
dublet the secret is a murky and
mysterious property of electrons called
spin we know that when an electrically
charged particle moves it produces a
magnetic field however experiments show
that electrons are actually producing
two separate magnetic fields and so they
must be moving in two different ways an
electron orbits around the atom but it
is also said to be spinning so in a way
an electron is similar to the Earth
which both spins on its axis and orbits
around the Sun except not quite for in
the case of electrons spin is just an
analogy they would have to be spinning
faster than the speed of light to
account for their observed Behavior
nonetheless physicists still use the
word spin to refer to the source of the
electron's second magnetic field and
fine structure results from these two
magnetic fields interacting with each
other like electron orbits and Doon bore
street food spin is also Quant ized only
certain quantities are allowed the spin
of the electron is 1/2 but this can be
either positive or negative so an
electron can exist in one of two spin
States up where its spin is plus a half
and down where its spin is minus a half
a spin up electron creates a magnetic
field that adds to the magnetic field
generated by its orbital motion boosting
the electron up to a slightly higher
energy level the magnetic field created
by a SP down electron works against the
orbital magnetic field relegating the
electron to a very slightly lower energy
level and so the two closely spaced H
Alpha lines in the hydrogen Spectrum are
produced by electrons dropping down from
these marginally different energy
levels D's Brilliance was to bring
together several breakthroughs in early
20th century physics in order to explain
the weirdness of spin
in 1926 inin schinger published his
famous Schrodinger equation just as a
light can act as both a particle and a
wave so can
electrons the Schrodinger equation
describes the behavior of these electron
waves dur also folded in Einstein's
special theory of relativity which
describes how objects behave when they
move at high speeds the result when
durra published his own equation in 1928
the one engraved on the plaque in
Westminster Abbey it showed that spin
becomes an inevitable property of the
electron once you treat it as a
relativistic Quantum
wave the bore model that describes
electrons as like orbiting planets is
consigned to the growing scrap heap of
theories physicists have been forced to
discard atoms are actually made of waves
and particles at the same time the fine
structure crack had opened up and
consumed the atom
whole but the best scientific theories
don't just explain something we already
know they also predict something that we
don't the dur equation Works whether or
not the particles it's describing have
positive or negative energy so dur
predicted the existence of a particle
identical to the electron but with the
opposite electric charge a particle of
antimatter and just four years after
durak published his equation the
positron was indeed found by Carl
Anderson
[Music]
son compared to the bore model the durac
equation was certainly a more
comprehensive set of rules for how the
game of subatomic chess works but by
this point physicists had understandably
become wary of closing the rule book and
they were right not to for as they would
soon discover there were yet two more
minuscule moves in a strange corner of
the board though were not covered by d's
rules and in an odd historical
coincidence both were announced at the
very same conference in
1947 during the second world war many of
the leading lights in physics were
repurposed to develop militarily useful
technology such as radar and atomic
bombs The Shelter Island Conference held
near Long Island in New York was a
chance to refocus on compiling the
ultimate rule book of the universe the
wonderfully named polycarp K announced
his measurements of a property of the
electron called its magnetic dipole
moment his answer disagreed with a
prediction by direct suggesting that
there was still something far deeper and
more mysterious at play and so to
explain this let's return to our bar
magnet it has two poles North and South
making it a dipole if you place the bar
magnet inside another magnetic field
then it will try to align with that
field like a compass needle swinging to
Point North the magnetic dipole moment
is a measure of the strength of this
interaction the spin of an electron
generates a magnetic field and so it is
like a tiny dipole magnet but the
question is how strong is its magnetic
dipole moment if you don't treat an
electron as a Quantum particle and
assume that it is a small sphere that's
actually rotating you get the wrong
answer the real value of the magnetic
dipole moment measured by Kush is about
twice as big this difference between the
quantum and non-quantum answers is
called the G Factor the dur equation
correctly treats the electron as a
Quantum object and it predicts that the
G Factor should be exactly two however
kush's measurements said otherwise the
answer he gets is
2238 this seemingly trivial difference
became known as the electron's anomalous
magnetic dipole moment it was yet
another neon sign Illuminating our
ignorance an unexplained Gambit in the
chess game of the
Gods but that was not the biggest shock
at Shelter
Island the war had seen huge strides
forward in microwave technology and in
his post-war experiments Willis lamb had
seen hydrogen atoms spitting out
microwave photons photons that simply
shouldn't exist exist according to the
durac equation two of the energy levels
within the hydrogen atom should coincide
instead lamb realized that they diverge
by just one part in a million when
electrons make the transition between
them they produce the microwave photons
lamb saw this unexpected energy level
split became known as the lamb
shift lamb would later reflect that it
was the smallest of measurements with
the biggest of ramifications could ran
Lamb's work would not only land them a
share of the 1955 Nobel Prize it would
press physicists into extending durx
equation into what would become the most
accurate and exquisitly tested theory in
the history of physics it would unite
all we knew about the electromagnetic
field and the quantum atom together into
a single Theory but with this
realization we'd be forced to accept a
truly bizarre new
reality
[Music]
quantum mechanics describes nature as
absurd from the point of view of Common
Sense and yet it fully agrees with
experiment so I hope you can accept
nature as she is
absurd for the physicist Andre gim it
was just another Friday night in the lab
for the Frog it must have felt like it
had been transported into orbit it
hovers in midair spinning and flipping
like an astronaut doing Som
assaults gim dedicates 10% of his time
to these seemingly outlandish
experiments along with the Frog G and
his team would levitate plants fish and
even a mouse using strong magnets his
efforts would win him the IG Nobel Prize
in 2000 a satiric alternative to the
Nobel Prize aimed at recognizing on
usual or trivial scientific
achievements and yet despite the
Whimsical nature of gim's experiments
you have a lot more incommon with his
levitating creatures than you may think
it might seem like you are currently
touching the chair you're sitting on or
the floor you're standing on but very
simply you aren't you are instead
floating on a cloud of particles when
you walk you are not in contact with the
ground at all instead you were standing
on a swarm of of subatomic specters
blink and you'll miss them ghost
particles that haunt the quantum
world this is the counterintuitive
reality of the Gods game of chess to
quote physicist Frank wilch what you see
isn't what you
[Music]
get the fact that we are all levitating
like gim's frog is the only logical way
to explain the seemingly tiny
inconsistencies seen by Kush and lamb
the smallest of effects with the
profoundest of
consequences it turned out that the dur
equation failed to account for cushion
lamb because although it treated the
electron as a Quantum object it still
described the electromagnetic field in
the way that Faraday and Maxwell did
back in the 19th century instead the
electromagnetic field also needed to be
quantized it had to be treated as a
Quantum field with all the mind ending
consequences that would entail and so
along with other physicists in the Years
following his breakthrough equation
durak began to develop a very bizarre
vision for our
[Music]
world imagine that the electromagnetic
field is represented by a string pluck
the string and you give it energy to
vibrate except that if this is a truly
Quantum field these vibrations can only
come in set predetermined sizes if you
don't give the field enough energy to
reach the smallest possible vibration
then nothing happens physicists have a
name for the smallest possible vibration
of an electromagnetic field a
photon photons and electrons therefore
aren't particles embedded in a field
they are the field photons Are
vibrations of the electromagnetic field
and an electron is the smallest possible
vibration of a separate
electron field these fields are
fundamental fill the universe and exist
whether a vibration what we call a
particle is there or
not here's another way to picture it
imagine that a field is made up of a
grid of tiles each one connected to a
spring initially the field is completely
stationary the tiles are all level and
there are no springs bouncing up and
down yet if you pull up one of the tiles
in effect injecting energy into a small
part of the field you can set one of the
Springs oscillating up and down this
localized vibration of a field is what
we see as a particle crucially though
the spring has some resistance if you
don't pull on the tile hard enough then
it won't budge in other words there's a
minimum amount of energy required to
create a
particle you can increase the size of
the oscillation by injecting more energy
but in the case of quantum Fields only
vibrations of set predetermined sizes
are allowed hence H why electrons need a
certain amount of energy to jump to a
higher orbital vibrations within Quantum
Fields only come in multiples of the
smallest possible vibration anything in
between is forbidden as well as this
vibrations in one Quantum field can be
transferred to another when physicists
say that an electron drops down an
energy level like in the Doon bore
lights what they really mean is that a
localized vibration in the electron
field vibrates less this lost energy is
transferred to the electromagnetic field
creating a localized vibration there
that we call a
photon picturing this process using
particles is perhaps easier to wrap your
head around but there aren't actually
any particles involved at all it is all
just vibrating Fields interacting with
one
another the idea of particles as mere
vibrations is known as Quantum field
Theory and it also explains the an
antimatter first predicted by durac an
electron is a vibration of the electron
field but its antimatter partner the
positron is a vibration of the same
field in the opposite direction the
equivalent of pulling the tile down
instead of up that's why the two
so-called particles have identical
properties save for their opposite
electric charges when an electron and a
positron meet their oscillations cancel
each other out and the electron field
stops vibrating their energy is
transferred to the electromagnetic field
which vibrates to create two photons
this is called Annihilation the reverse
can also happen when a photon's energy
is transferred to the electron field to
create an electron positron pair
unsurprisingly this process is called
pair production it was durak who first
came up with a name for this theory of
how light and matter interact he called
it quantum
electrodynamics or
QED
but how do these Quantum Fields explain
kush's anomalous measurement of the
electron's magnetic dipole moment and
the lamb shift and where did the ghostly
particles you're levitating on fit in
the answer would come from physicist
Julian
schinger born in New York in 1918
schinger fell in love with physics
during a lecture by dur that he attended
when he was just 14 years old by 16 he'd
enrolled as an undergraduate at the City
College of New York clearly a precocious
Talent legendary physicist Hans beer
said of a 17-year-old schinger his
knowledge of quantum electrodynamics is
certainly equal to my own and I could
hardly understand how he could acquire
that knowledge in less than 2
years if QED explains the interaction
between light and electrons through
Quantum Fields those fields must also be
subject to all the rules of the
counterintuitive Quantum world and that
includes the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle is a loan agreement with the
universe it says that you can borrow
energy from empty space as long as you
pay it back again within a certain
amount of time the more energy you
borrow the quicker you have to pay it
back this borrowed energy can pull up a
tile and vibrate a Quantum field to
create a particle but then that
vibration disappears again once the
energy debt is repaid physicists refer
to these ghostly vibrations as virtual
particles it means that an electron is
never really alone the electromagnetic
field around it is constantly vibrating
with borrowed energy creating a swarm of
virtual photons that flit in and out of
existence sometimes the virtual photons
exist for long enough that they undergo
pair production to produce virtual
electron positron pairs but they also
soon disappear before they vanish these
Poltergeist particles Buffet the real
electron into a slightly different
energy level inside the hydrogen atom
which is exactly what Willis Lam had
observed they also influenced the
electron magnetic interactions
explaining why kushi's measured G Factor
was slightly higher than in the dur
equation which doesn't treat the
electromagnetic field as a Quantum
field in the years since physicists have
measured the magnetic dipole moment of
the El to an unbelievable level of
accuracy according to QED the electron G
Factor should have a value of 2.0
43552 in February 2023 physicists
announc the most precise measurement of
the electron G Factor ever made their
Answer
2.23 1
3612 correct to about 1 part in a
trillion making QED the most accurately
tested theory in the history of physics
it's the same as measuring the distance
to the Moon to within less than the
width of a human
hair without the presence of virtual
particles the G Factor would be exactly
two they may come and go but their
ghostly influence leaves an imprint on
the real world that is there for all to
see it's as if a piece on the chessboard
has moved without anyone ever actually
touching it our rule book has to include
these Phantom moves
too the fleeting existence of virtual
particles has profound implications for
the way we explain the world around us
starting with how magnets work out goes
farad's 19th century idea of field lines
and incomes the exchange of virtual
photons imagine that you and a friend
are each standing on a boat if you throw
balls back and forth between you the
boats will move apart in the same way
two matching magnetic poles move apart
by exchanging virtual photons if the
poles are opposites then they attract
each other also by exchanging virtual
photons but this time in a way that's a
bit like throwing boomerangs between the
boats instead of balls in a similar
fashion it's virtual photons that make
up the cloud upon which you are
currently levitating like G's frog
electrons orbit so far out from the
nucleus that atoms are mostly empty
space you should fall straight through
the chair or the floor as atoms pass
through atoms unhindered that you don't
it's only because the electrons in the
floor or the chair and the electrons in
you are constantly exchanging virtual
photons pushing each other apart like
two Magnetic North Poles without ever
actually touching you are forever
floating on the most ephemeral of
quantum clouds
physicists have juggled with the
implications of virtual particles ever
since Heisenberg introduced his
uncertainty principle in
1927 within 2 years scher's PhD
supervisor and later father of the
atomic bomb Robert Oppenheimer realized
they presented a big problem for the
success of QED when he used an early
version of the theory to add up the
contribution of the multitudes of
virtual particles swarming around in a
electron it suggested that the energy in
electron emits as it changes energy
levels is
infinite QED could seemingly not explain
something as basic as the spectral lines
of hydrogen so beautifully explained by
both bore and duraq calculations of the
mass and charge of the electron also
gave Infinity as the answer Infinity
isn't even a number but instead the
notion or idea of endlessness when it
crops up in physics it is another a big
neon sign imploring physicists to try
harder this Infinity problem meant that
Q looked Dead on Arrival yet another
false Dawn but this was not to be the
end for the theory for it was to
eventually be salvaged by schinger and
others in the 1940s using an incredibly
powerful theoretical
[Music]
technique the lamb shift and the
electron anomalous magnetic dipole
moment had shown physicists that the
effect of virtual particles is finite
and not infinite the influence they have
is measurable theorists didn't have to
fully understand why QED initially gave
the wrong answer all they needed to do
was tweak their equations in such a way
that they produced the values measured
by lamb and Kush altering a theory in
this way to Vanquish The Unwanted
infinities is a mathematical Conjuring
act called
renormalization and scientists use the
technique to this day to blast through
seemingly impenetrable
problems and so these two tiny effects
in a shadowy corner of the cosmic
chessboard became doubly important not
only did they show that D's initial set
of rules was incomplete they also helped
to improve the set of rules that
replaced it the Infinities were over
come and suddenly QED was a working
Theory capable of predicting real
outcomes with startling Precision the
first true Quantum field
Theory schinger would go on to share the
1965 Nobel Prize with Richard fean and
Cino tomonaga the other Grand Masters
who also figured out the route to
renormalization but the Staggering
success of QED set physicists wondering
if the electrom magnetic force between
magnets could be so exquisitely
explained as nothing more than ripples
in a Quantum field what about Nature's
other forces how far could they
go how much of reality could be
explained as mere
vibrations in
fields because Atomic behavior is so
unlike ordinary experience it's very
difficult to get used to and it appears
peculiar and mysterious to everyone both
to the novice and the experienced
physicist the trail of people marching
out of the wooden huts and over the
chilot pass resembles an army of ants
the bootprints left by their frostbitten
feet snake for miles around the
mountains 100,000 eager explorers have
descended on Canada as Yukon River and
the surrounding Klondike region a frenzy
sparked by the discovery of gold but
most never even make it to the gold
Fields forced to turn back empty-handed
by the elements or Worse killed by
infectious diseases Avalanches or
assault today the Klondike is far more
Serene than it was during the Gold Rush
at the end of the 19th century but the
precious metal is still mined here and
in 2022 miners une Earth very different
kind of treasure buried in the
permafrost a perfectly preserved woolly
mammoth scientists estimate that the
mammoth lived around 30,000 years ago
but how do they know it is the answer to
that question that provides the key to
the next set of quantum rules for ever
since the mammoth died a subatomic clock
has been silently ticking away inside it
a Time piece based on atoms of carbon 14
the nucleus of a carbon 14 atom contains
six protons and eight particles called
neutrons occasionally one of the
neutrons spontaneously shape shifts into
a proton as it's the number of protons
that distinguishes different chemical
elements from one another it is no
longer an atom of carbon it is now an
atom of nitrogen with seven protons and
seven
neutrons this random process is called
radioactive decay
and the more carbon atoms that have
changed to nitrogen the older the
specimen must
be but this type of radioactive decay is
governed by an entirely different Force
than the one that controls magnets and
electrons a force that appears to be
considerably more feeble hence its name
the weak
force and the story of how physicists
came to truly understand the rules of
the weak force and its various moves on
the board began in the Bronx High School
of C in New York City way back in
1950 that year the graduating class at
Bronx High contained not one but two
future Nobel Prize winners not only that
they would win the same prize in the
same year for contributions to the very
same Theory despite working on it
separately they were shelin glashow and
Steven
Weinberg both glashow and Weinberg ended
up at Cornell University after
weinberg's father drove them around to
look at various colleges after
graduating glasow moved to Harvard to
complete a PhD under the watchful eye of
Julian schinger having renormalized
Quantum electrodynamics schinger set
glashow thinking about whether the weak
Force could also be explained using a
Quantum
field we've already seen how the
electromagnetic force is carried by
virtual photons that flit between the
poles of a magnet and even between your
feet and the floor physicists call such
Force carrying particles
bons but which Bon is responsible for
fering the weak
Force the answer lies partly in the
decay of carbon 14 into nitrogen 14 used
in carbon dating the weak Force turns an
electrically neutral Neutron into a
positively charged proton along with an
electron and a particle called an
electron anti neutrino this process is
called beta minus decare but it can
happen the other way around too during
beta plus Decay a proton changes into a
neutron plus a positron and an electron
neutrino in other words the weak force
is able to change a particle's electric
charge a photon the boson of the
electromagnetic force does not have this
power when an electron absorbs a photon
it stays negatively charged so the weak
Force must have at least two bons one
involved in changing neutral to positive
and another in changing positive to
neutral it was Weinberg who chose the
letter W for weak giving us the w+ and W
minus
[Music]
bons and so physicists including
schinger and gasha attempted to explain
these weak Force interactions using a
Quantum field Theory just as they had
done for the electromagnetic
force these W bosons were reason to be
the minimal possible vibrations of the W
field just as the photon is for the
electromagnetic field just like the
photons flying between magnets the w+
and W minus bosons involved in the two
forms of beta Decay are also virtual
pisted particles that disrupt reality
before quickly disappearing back into
the quantum shadows in this way we date
archaeological Treasures with the help
of particles that aren't really there
except turning the weak Force into a
fully-fledged quantum field theory was
proving more than a little tricky for
one thing the mathematics predicted
three bosons not two and so glasow
suggests the existence of a new
electrically neutral boson instead Z for
the fact it has zero
charge so the weak force is carried by
three bosons W + W minus and Zed they
are the product of two different Quantum
Fields one for the two W's and one for
the Zed progress is made but there is a
bigger problem this Trio of bons has
mass they must do because the distance
over which the weak Force operates what
physicists refer to as its range is Tiny
just 100th of a trillionth of a
millimeter this Behavior suggests that
virtual bons responsible for carrying
the weak Force disappear incredibly
quickly before they can get very far the
time it takes for half of them to
disappear known as their halflife is
just three 10 septian of a second there
are more of those half lives in a single
second than have been second since the
Big Bang some 13.8 billion years ago and
this is why it's called the weak Force
it's not that it's inherently weak when
it does ACT instead the weak Force
rarely acts at all because the virtual
bons that carry it disappear so
quickly the reason that a very short
lifetime means that weak bons have a
significant amount of M mass is again
the Heisenberg uncertainty principle the
loan agreement with nature that is
responsible for virtual particles in the
first
place remember you can borrow a little
energy for a long time or a lot of
energy for a little time the incredibly
short lives of weak bosons suggest they
must have borrowed a lot of energy
according to Einstein's famous equation
eal mc² high energy also means high mass
and so the weak bosons are reach around
100 times heavier than a proton or
160,000 times heavier than an
electron but this through a spanner in
the works weak bosons having Mass meant
that renormalization the fabulous trick
that physicists use to Vanquish
Infinities from Quantum electrodynamics
only worked for massless bosons like
photons the Infinities were still all to
present if you wanted to treat the weak
Force as a Quantum field and its bosons
as its
vibrations and so it was Glow's old
school friend Steven Weinberg who helped
figure out the way through the Quagmire
with a remarkable thought yet another
condensing of the rules what if the
electromagnetic field and the weak field
were once one and the same while
physicists had been busy trying to write
the quantum rule book of the God's chess
game astronomers had realized that the
Universe began as an incredibly small
hot point known as the Big Bang together
physicists and astronomers began to
explore the possibility that there was
originally one so-called Electro weak
field which separated out into the
electromagnetic and weak Fields as the
universe expanded and cooled if this
Electro weak field had massless bons
before the separation then it could be
treated as a Quantum field without being
plagued by the infinity problem the
issue then became how to go from one
field with massless bons to two separate
Fields only one of which has bons with
mass and this is how Weinberg got it to
[Music]
work let's say the electro weak field
had four massless bons we'll call them
W1 W2 W3 and B another field also needs
to have existed which we'll call the H
field
the H field is initially dormant but
spontaneously activates bringing its own
four bons into play they are called H+ H
minus h0 and little H the activation of
the H field breaks the underlying
symmetry of the electro weak field and
it separates out into the weak and
electromagnetic fields the H bosons also
have the power to give other bosons
Mass the W1 and H+ bosons combine into
the w+ and the W2 combines with the H
minus into the W minus W3 and B merge to
create two new massless bosons one of
them combines with h0 to make the Zed
boson and the other one never combines
with an H boson and so it never gains
Mass it is the massless
photon by now there's a chance you may
have guessed what all the h's stand for
higs and therein lies the beauty of this
Electro week Theory sometimes called
Quantum flavor Dynamics or qfd not only
does it explain why the weak bosons have
mass and the photon does not it also
makes a big prediction one of the four
original H bosons little H should have
survived this convoluted process
unscathed and so began the search for
perhaps the most loaded particle in
physics
history the higs
Bon
schoolmates glashow and Weinberg shared
the 1979 Nobel Prize in physics
alongside Pakistani physicist abta Salam
for their work on this Electro week
unification suddenly we didn't need one
set of rules to explain the
electromagnetic field and a separate set
to explain the weak field the rules of
the electro weak field sufficed in much
the same way James Clark Maxwell had
United the electric and magnetic fields
into a single electromagnetic field in
the first place two seemingly totally
different rules blended into one
underlying
framework but this was not the end for
while theoretical physicists had been
mapping all of this out experimental
physicists had continued to probe deeper
and deeper inside the
atom and in doing so had found a zoo of
particles and a whole new layer to
reality the protons and neutrons within
atoms also turned out to be made of
smaller particles governed by yet
another fundamental Force could this
also be explained with Quantum
Fields was the very matter that made up
atoms simply
vibrations
[Music]
too you can't say a is made of b or vice
versa all mass is
interaction your heart is pounding in
your chest as the deafening wind Roars
past your face as you hurtle towards the
ground a heavy dose of adrenaline cses
through your veins then at the very last
second the bungee cord snaps you back
from the brink of
Oblivion this White Knuckle ride is
similar to the experience of subatomic
particles called quarks they make up the
protons and neutrons found in the heart
parts of atoms except if they try to
free themselves from these particles
they are always wrenched back in
independently proposed by murel man and
George Z in 1964 protons and neutrons
are made of two different types of these
quarks up and down inside a proton
you'll find two up quarks and one down
Quark the up quarks each carry an
electric charge of plus 2/3 and the down
Quark an electric charge of minus A3 so
the proton has an overall positive
electric charge a neutron has only one
upark the charge of which is canceled
out to neutral by its two down quarks
and so there is no such thing as the
Proton or Neutron field instead there is
only the upcar field and the down Quark
field up and down quarks are the minimal
possible vibrations of these Quantum
Fields the objects we call protons and
neutrons are actually two different
Quantum Fields vibrating in tandem the
very atoms that make up our reality are
nothing but interconnected vibrating
[Music]
Fields however understanding protons and
neutrons in terms of quarks did present
physicists with some challenges firstly
like electrical charges repel each other
just as like magnetic poles do so why
don't the two positively charged up
quarks in the proton push apart or the
negatively charged down quarks in the
neutron physicists reasoned that there
must be another attractive Force at play
mightier than the electromagnetic force
the strong
force like the electromagnetic force the
strong force is also carried by massless
bosons this time called gluons because
it's only by exchanging them that quarks
stay glued together gluons are the
minimal possible vibrations of the gluon
field but of course as we have seen time
and time again there was still one small
issue that would bring this new Theory
to Breaking
Point for in 1964 the same year quarks
were proposed physicists had discovered
a truly baffling
particle the Omega minus
particle the Quark zoo is home to beasts
more exotic than up and down quarks
there are also flavors of Quark called
strange charm top and bottom each one is
the minimum possible vibration of its
own Quantum field meaning there are six
Quark fields in total the problem was
that the Troublesome Omega minus
particle was made up of three strange
quarks and this seemed to break a sacran
law of quantum physics known as the POI
Exclusion Principle we've already seen
that all electrons have a property
called spin with value equal to a half
likewise quarks also have spin equal to
a half the PO exclusion principle states
that it's impossible for two spin half
particles to exist in exactly the same
Quantum state but what about the Three
Strange quarks in the Omega minus
particle let's say one of them has a
spin of plus one2 and a second has a
spin of minus one2 what about the third
it doesn't matter if its spin is
positive or negative either way it will
still be in exactly the same state as
one of its neighbors in direct violation
of the POI exclusion principle The Omega
minus particle was another big neon sign
another crack in a theory that slowly
revealed a whole new layer of ideas it
told physicists that quarks must be
ruled by some extra property that
distinguishes them instead something
electrons don't
have
color
color is the charge associated with the
strong force just as electric charge is
associated with the
electromagnetic a quark can have one of
three color charges called red blue and
green quarks don't actually have
different Hues though like spin color is
just an analogy using colors to name the
three strong force charges was the
brainchild of physicist Wally Greenberg
who took inspiration from someone we've
met before James Clark Maxwell in the
1860s Maxwell demonstrated that
combining red blue and green light
creates white light in other words all
color disappears when the three are
mixed equally when one of each red blue
and green color charge combine they
create a particle with a neutral color
charge protons neutrons and Omega minus
particles don't behave like they have
this strong force charge so they must be
color neutral that means they are made
of one red Quark one blue quark and one
green Quark no two quarks are exactly
the same and the PO Exclusion Principle
is
saved and the fact that physicists use
colors to name strong force charges
gives the quantum field theory of the
strong force its name Quantum
chromodynamics or
qcd Quantum electrodynamics has one Bon
the photon and Quantum flavor Dynamics
added a trio of weak bosons the w+ W
minus and Zed however qcd says that the
strong force is carried by a total of
eight bosons an octet of multicolored
gluons here's
[Music]
why like all Force carrying particles
the exchanged gluons that stick quarks
together are virtual Children of the
Heisenberg un certainty principle we've
already seen how virtual photons can
turn into virtual particle anti-particle
pairs that nudge real electrons
similarly a virtual glue on can turn
into a virtual Quark anti- Quark pair if
quarks carry red blue and green charges
then anti- quarks carry anti- red
anti-blue and anti-green charges so the
strong charge on a glue on is a mixture
of a color and an anti-color when a quk
absorbs a gluon containing a particular
color charge it changes to that color so
a blue Quark absorbing a gluon
containing red charge turns red
conversely when a quark emits a gluon
containing an anti- color it changes to
that color so a green Quark spitting out
a gluon containing anti-blue charge
turns blue this makes it impossible for
a glue on to be made of a color and its
own anti-color let's say a red Quark
could emit blue anti-blue gluons this
would both turn itself blue and turn the
green Quark blue when it absorbs them
you'd have two blue quarks inside the
same particle there would no longer be
one of each color to mix together to be
color neutral so the Proton or Neutron
would exhibit some overall color charge
which they never do there are six ways
to pair off three colors so that you
never get matching colors in the same
pair that's six gluons but what about
the other two the quantum World being
the weird and counterintuitive realm
that it is there are actually two
complicated ways for each Quark or
antiquark to be a mix of colors while
still leading to a neutral color charge
this makes protons and neutrons like
miniature universes Relentless hives of
activity constantly shifting
kaleidoscopes of color charges with a
rainbow of virtual gluons quarks and
antiquarks flitting here and there these
virtual particles are so abundant that
they make up 99% of the mass of a proton
or neut neon the real quarks they are
buzzing between contribute just
1% the very particles that make up every
atom in your body are mostly made of
things that aren't really
[Music]
there you can think of the constant back
and forth of gluons between quarks as
like a bungee cord between them
physicists call it a qcd string try and
pull a quark out of a proton and the
bungee cord tenses and wrenches the
Quark back in like our bungee jumper
earlier it is possible to put in enough
energy to snap the bungee cord
completely yet this still doesn't set
the Quark free instead the energy is
converted into a quark antiquark pair
called a Mison the Mison escapes and
Carries away the energy but the Quark
remains trapped collisions within
particle accelerators are so energetic
that the bungee cord is broken multiple
times spitting out an abundance of me on
they form Jets and it's these jets that
particle physicists pour over for hints
about what has happened only then the
signs of color emerge as it's
transferred from particle to
particle yet these virtual meons have an
even more important role to
play in most Atomic nuclei there are
multiple protons each with a positive
electric charge like all electrically
charged particles they're exchanging
virtual photons which acts to p push
them apart yet this is trumped by the
virtual meons they are also exchanging
which keeps them glued together
physicists call this the strong nuclear
force to distinguish it from the strong
force that binds quarks they can also
stick a proton and a neutron together
every element in the periodic table
heavier than hydrogen would be
impossible without these virtual
meons no stars no planets no life so not
only are the particles You're Made Of
mostly comprised of things that don't
really exist those things are also held
together by things that don't really
exist
either the more we figure out the rules
of quantum chess The Stranger and
stranger they
[Music]
become in 2004 David gra David pollitzer
and Frank wilch shared the Nobel Prize
in physics for their work on quantum
chromodynamics they showed that the
strong force and all its Myriad color
interactions can be described using a
renormalizable Quantum field Theory just
as the electromagnetic and weak forces
can that quarks gluons and misons are
all just ghostly vibrations in Quantum
Fields this means that currently
everything in the atomic world can be
explained using just two theories the
electro weak Theory which includes
quantum flavor Dynamics and Quantum
electrodynamics within it and Quantum
chromodynamics together they make up the
standard model of particle
physics the standard model describes a
total of 17 vibrating overlapping
Quantum Fields occupying every part of
space there are four Fields associated
with the force carrying bons the photon
the W bosons The Zed boson and the gluon
then six quark Fields one for each
flavor there are also six Fields known
as lepton fields leptons are particles
not affected by the strong force that
includes the electron field and two
Fields associated with particles called
the muon and the TOA plus a trio fields
for the three different kinds of
neutrino that's a total of 16 but what
about the 17th
field that is the much lorded higs field
vibrations of which we know as the higs
Bon that Bon was discovered in the
summer of 2012 at cern's Large Hadron
cider a cavernous cathedral built to
prize answers from the standard model
the discovery of the higs was a ringing
endorsement of the standard model as the
most comprehensive rule book for the
gods chess game ever compiled it
successfully explains how all subatomic
particles and three of the fundamental
forces can be described as mere
vibrations of across its 17 different
Quantum Fields waves and particles mass
and energy light air Earth and the
matter that makes up me and you almost
everything could be reduced to
vibrations in vast Universe spanning
interacting Quantum
Fields almost
because for all of the standard model
successes there is still one thing left
one rule that just doesn't
fit
gravity if a lore does not work even in
one place where it ought to it is just
wrong clad in gleaming white space suits
a team of astronauts check effects the
last of the rivets and bolts an armada
of robotic spacecraft sets to work
cooling the magnets to a temperature
lower than even empty space
itself after centuries of toil the much
anticipated machine is finally ready to
call it vast would be an understatement
it encircles the sun like the path of a
planet orbiting far beyond any of the
actual planets of the solar system its
total length stretching to some 30 7
billion
kilm and physicists are about to send
subatomic particles in opposite
directions around this super ring at
close to the speed of light even though
the particles are traveling at almost
300,000 kilomet per second physicists
won't see the first collisions for a day
and a half even then they'll need the
particles to make millions of laps
before they have enough data to piece
together what's going on they will need
to be patient it won't be for
Generations s until they finally see the
results the particles have to stream
past the robots mining the space rocks
in the asteroid belt for the materials
required to make machines like this one
by the Towering cities of New New York
and New New Del on the dusty Martian
surface and Beyond the sprawling solar
Farms on Mercury that are powering
Humanity's growing presence across the
solar system this Mega machine is the
ultimate microscope
allowing physicists to zoom in and see
reality at the smallest scales with its
incredibly High energies this Ultra
Hadron Collider is probing the so-called
plank length which is just 62 nonilon of
a millimeter across there are around a
billion times more plank lengths in a
single millimeter than there are stars
in the entire observable
[Music]
universe
it is only by exploring the universe in
such minute detail that physicists can
hunt for proof of what has always eluded
them a theory capable of explaining
every phenomenon in the known universe
from the tiniest subatomic particle to
the most gargantuan Galaxy a theory that
proves once and for all that everything
even gravity can be explained as ripples
within Quantum
Fields a theory of quantum
gravity such an experiment is clearly a
long way off but it represents the dream
scenario for many physicists just as the
electromagnetic and weak forces were
once united into the electro weak Force
physicists suspect the electro weak
force was once Tangled Up with the
strong force into a single Quantum field
the fact that both have already been
successfully described using Quantum
field theories shows that they are
highly compatible they look to be like
two pieces of a locket naturally fitting
together to make a
hole the marriage of the two is known as
Grand unified theory and it is an
inherently testable idea for one thing
physicists suspect it could lead to
proton decay where the proton breaks
down into lighter particles and so
searches are already underway for proof
of this process evidence that in turn
the gravitational field was once spliced
together with the grand unified field
into a single quantum field is what our
solar system sized accelerator was
looking for just as the other three
forces have Force carrying bons our
future physicists r on the hunt for the
graviton the minimum possible vibration
of the quantized gravitational field yet
despite this being a superficially
logical extension such a notion is
fundamentally incompatible with the way
physicists currently understand
gravity
Alber theory of gravity is Albert
Einstein's general theory of relativity
it says that the universe is made of a
fabric called SpaceTime if as
Shakespeare wrote all the worlds a stage
then SpaceTime is the stage and Quantum
Fields merely players upon it the 17
Quantum fields of the standard model
vibrate in space and over time SpaceTime
is space and time
time according to general relativity
mass or energy embedded in SpaceTime
creates a Depression known as a gravity
well if a second object gets trapped in
this gravity well then it will look like
the first object is preventing it from
escaping by pulling on it Isaac Newton
thought that this was the attractive
force of gravity but gravity isn't
really a force at all it's just the
effect of the curved SpaceTime inside a
gravity well by describing it in this
way general relativity treats gravity
very differently to the way Quantum
field theories explain the other three
fundamental forces through the exchange
of virtual bon in general relativity
there's no bungee cord of virtual
gravitons traveling between the Sun and
the Earth and trying to explain gravity
through the exchange of virtual
gravitons instead is immensely
Troublesome for one thing there's a
problem when physicists calculate the
chances of a particle emitting or
absorbing a graviton the answer they get
is significantly higher than one in
probability the likelihood of events is
scored on a scale from impossible at
zero to certain but one a probability of
more than one is saying that an event is
somehow more certain than certain said
another way there's more than 100%
chance of it happening this is clearly
nonsense and yet another red neon
warning sign but there's an even bigger
issue let's say the sun in the Earth
really are exchanging gravitons those
gravitons have energy so they would warp
SpaceTime which would lead to more
gravitons they too would warp SpaceTime
leading to yet more gravitons very
quickly this spirals out of control and
races towards Infinity resulting in the
equations blowing up and losing their
predictive
Powers if this sounds familiar you're
not imagining it this is exactly the
same problem that plagued early versions
of quantum
electrodynamics Robert Oppenheimer added
up the effect of all the virtual
particles swarming around the electron
and he got Infinity as the answer
blushes were only spared because the
lamb shift and kushy's unexpected
measurement of the electron's magnetic
dipole moment showed physicists how to
fudge their equations to produce the
right answer through
renormalization but physicists don't yet
know how to renormalize quantum gravity
and Vanquish the Infinities maybe
another tiny Gambit will one day blast a
whole in either general relativity or
the standard Model A final move in the
centuries old game of divine chess that
physicists have yet to observe one that
would help them to complete the rule
book once and for all perhaps it will
take a solar system sized accelerator to
find
it but in the meantime physicists have
tried other ways to break the impass and
the most famous attempt is string theory
String Theory says that the particles
described as fundamental in the standard
model such as quarks and electrons
aren't fundamental at all but are
instead made of tiny vibrating strings
just as you can play different strings
on different musical instruments to
produce different nodes so the universe
creates the orchestral Masterpiece of
the standard model by conducting its own
string section open strings would have
the properties of photons and gluons but
a closed string could have all the
expected properties of a
graviton except there are a number of
Fairly sizable catches to get rid of the
problem of the probabilities adding up
to more than one string theory has to
invoke the influence of new particles
that no one has ever seen to Vanquish
the Infinities you also have to assume
that SpaceTime has at least nine spatial
Dimensions perhaps more as we only see
four dimensions three of space and one
of time the others must be curled up
really small and out of
site normally fineman's chess game gets
simpler as successive unifications draw
the rules together String Theory however
seems to make it inherently more
complicated with the need for a slew of
new playing pieces what makes it even
more complex is that there are countless
versions of string theory and string
theorists are sure which set of rules to
use to make testable predictions to see
if it's
correct so what other options are there
when pressed many physicists will
concede that general relativity seems
more likely to crack first we've seen
many times how the discovery of some new
Gambit forced physicists to throw away
an existing non-quantum theory in favor
of a new Quantum
one perhaps we haven't seen the thing
that breaks general relativity yet
because we haven't probed small enough
regions of SpaceTime and this idea is
far from new one man was thinking about
it as far back as the
1930s
born in what is now Ukraine in 1906 matf
Bronstein's work span an impressive
gamut of subjects from semiconductors to
Quantum electrodynamics and cosmology
but it is his 1935 paper on the problem
of quantum gravity for which he is most
remembered let's say we want to measure
a really small region of SpaceTime
bronstein imagined placing a particle
there to help us make the measurement
it's here that the heis ber uncertainty
principle re-enters our story we've
already encountered the version relating
energy borrowed for a certain amount of
time but bronstein considered another
version involving the position of a
particle this version says that as you
explore smaller and smaller distances
you need a particle with a higher and
higher energy to do so but Einstein's
eal mc² tells us that energy means Mass
eventually there comes a point when the
distance you're probing becomes so small
that the particle you need creates a
gravity well so deep that nothing can
escape and physicists already have a
name for an inescapable gravity well a
black hole your test particle has
created its own black hole and since you
can't see inside a black hole you can no
longer measure the particle in other
words there's a minimum distance below
which it is not possible to measure
anything just like there's a minimum
vibration of a Quantum field you've
zoomed in and found that SpaceTime
doesn't look the same at the smallest
scales after all if true SpaceTime would
not be the smooth and continuous fabric
that general relativity describes
instead it would come in multiples of
the smallest possible size bronstein had
hit upon another way that SpaceTime
could be
quantized however the bright flame of
Bronstein's genius was soon to be
extinguished just 3 years after the
publication of his work he was executed
in a Leningrad prison as part of Joseph
Stalin's Great Purge his wife Lydia was
told he'd been sentenced to 10 years of
hard labor he was just 31 years
old but where bronstein began others
would eventually follow today his work
has morphed into the theory of loop
quantum
gravity according to this Theory
SpaceTime is like a piece of of clothing
from a distance it looks like a smooth
fabric but Zoom down far enough and
you'll see that it's really made of a
network of individual stitches these are
the loops in Loop quantum gravity the
threads with which the quantum
gravitational field is woven each Loop
is unimaginably Tiny there would be more
Loops in a cubic centimeter of space
than there are cubic centim of space in
the entire observable universe somewhere
in the region of 10 followed by 99
zeros each Loop is a Quantum of the
gravitational field so Loop quantum
gravity does away with the need for
gravitons and all the problems that come
with them however so far like string
theory there is no experimental evidence
that Loop quantum gravity is the right
approach
[Music]
either and so perhaps this Quest will be
passed down to distant Generations who
will build particle accelerators the
size of the solar system to peer down
into the depths of reality maybe then
Loop quantum gravity or some similar
Theory will relegate SpaceTime from its
role as the stage on which all Quantum
Fields tread the boards to just another
quantum
field then there would be no stage at
all our entire reality would be created
through Quantum field stacked upon
Quantum
field a universe made of nothing more
than ethereal ripples
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like And
subscribe and leave us a comment to tell
us what you think thanks for watching
and we'll see you next
time